[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: Good evening.
I would like to welcome you
to the fourth in the series
of the Ford/MIT Nobel
Laureate lectures,
and we would like
to thank Ford Motor
Company for their
sponsorship of this series.
Tonight's speaker is
Professor David Baltimore,
president of California
Institute of Technology.
Professor Baltimore is
not a stranger to MIT.
He was a professor of
biology in the Cancer Center
at MIT for many years, and
was the founding director
of the Whitehead Institute for
biomedical research at MIT.
And in that , capacity, and in
other capacities as president
of Caltech, he has made
great contributions,
both to biological research
and to National Science policy.
In fact, he told me he
still has a lab at Caltech.
Doctor Baltimore helped to
pioneer the molecular study
of animal viruses
and his research
has had profound implications
for understanding cancer
and AIDS.
He was awarded the
Nobel Prize in 1975
for his work in
virology, specifically
for the interaction
between tumor viruses
and the genetic
material of the cell.
Dr. Baltimore has been
a major figure in the US
as head of the NIH AIDS
Vaccine Research Committee.
He was awarded the 1999 Medal
of Science in recognition
of his research
achievements, his excellence
in building scientific
institutions,
and his ability to
foster communication
between scientists
and the public.
I'd like to also remind
you there'll be a reception
after the lecture in the lobby.
His talk tonight is entitled,
Building a Community on Trust.
David.
[APPLAUSE]
BALTIMORE: It's a great
pleasure to have the opportunity
to be back at MIT, to be
back in Kresge Auditorium--
one of the great
venues in the world--
and to see many old friends.
I'm particularly happy that Dr.
Zella Luria came here tonight,
and I thank her.
Her husband Salvador Luria,
as many of you will know,
played a central
role in my life,
played a central role
in the life of MIT,
and was himself
a Nobel Laureate.
When I was asked to do this,
I faced a difficult choice
because although
I have ascended--
some might say descended--
to the role of President
of a university,
I still find it easiest to
discuss molecular biology.
It's second easiest
to discuss Caltech.
Because those are things
that I know very well.
But neither of them seemed
right for this occasion
Chuck Vest and Bob
Sylvie had certainly not
invited me because they wanted
to learn about transcription
factors or about
signal transduction
in the immune system.
I think they were looking
for something with a wider
interest.
And I don't think they wanted my
fund-raising pitch for Caltech.
[LAUGHTER]
So in this period of talking
about something that I
personally know
well, I thought I
would take on a topic that
has been a concern of mine
for a very long time, which
is the critical role of trust
in human relations.
I hasten to assure you that
I know that this is turf
on which I am crazy to tread.
Trust is at the heart of
philosophical theories
about human
motivation, about which
my own knowledge is minimal.
So I approached
this as an amateur.
Trust is a central
part of our lives,
but an ephemeral concept.
It is like the golden rule--
you can trust me
if I reciprocate
and then we have an effective
relationship and community.
But trust has been
falling out of fashion.
With the methods
of surveillance we
have today, with the
power of computers
to detect fraud it
might seem that we
can enforce moral behavior.
We can put our trust in
our methods of control,
not in people.
But I think September 11th
and the Enron scandals
have raised serious
doubts about our ability
to use technology to assure
transparency and moral
behavior.
As far as I can see trust,
is more important than ever,
because technology may
help in monitoring behavior
but it also provides the
tools for obfuscation--
that's the hardest word in
the English language to say--
chicanery, and downright fraud.
Two of the formative
events in my life
took place at MIT and both
centrally involved trust.
The first was the formation
of the Whitehead Institute,
which is now 20 years ago.
And for those of you
who do not remember,
let me remind you that
when Jack Whitehead offered
to fund this Institute with
$135 million of his own money,
the response was not
joy but suspicion.
It was fueled from
various fronts,
including the Boston Globe
and certain members of the MIT
faculty.
And I had been tapped by Jack
to try to build this Institute,
but he wasn't particularly
committed to MIT as its host.
It was I who desperately
wanted to be here,
and so there ensued a year
of negotiation when I tried--
ultimately successfully-- to
convince the MIT community
that Jack Whitehead
was not trying
to hijack its essence to
his own ends, but rather
was trying to build
an institution that
would add to the
intellectual power of MIT.
We crafted an
affiliation agreement
that governs the relationship
between these two institutions
to this day, but we all
knew that no piece of paper
could define all of
the interactions.
There had to be trust.
The year was actually spent
developing that trust.
I remember the final faculty
meeting where the relationship
was cemented, and
the argument that
carried the day was that MIT
was built by taking chances--
meaning that we had only
developed the minimum level
of trust necessary.
And it took years more
before it was evident
that the Whitehead
Institute, wanted nothing
more than to be a productive
member of this community.
The other formative
event was the affair
of Thereza Imanishi-Kari.
This evolved over 10 years and
has been chronicled in books,
and so I will not
attempt to recap it here.
However, at its
heart was the trust
necessary to carry out
collaborative scientific work.
As I will say later, I think
this is a fundamental aspect
of the scientific
enterprise, especially today,
as science is becoming
more interdisciplinary.
That she was
ultimately vindicated
in her assertion of the
rectitude of her behavior
showed that my trust
in her was well-placed.
However, it underlined
a critical aspect
of any collaborative
activity, which
is that both sides have
to satisfy themselves
that their trust is justified.
It's a tricky
business, because it
involves recognizing
that a bit of suspicion
is appropriate, even while the
relationship must be a trusting
one.
A friend of mine who writes
about how organizations
function puts trust at the
center of his analysis,
but he says that
trust is something
you have to give upon
entering a relationship
with another person.
In science, it is
true that we assume
that a colleague is
trustworthy, and only
in extremis do we doubt
his or her honesty.
While a colleague
whom we may never
have met, when such a colleague
comes to give a seminar, we
don't ask that the colleague
prove his or her veracity,
we assume that.
But in a collaboration, where
both parties will ultimately
have to vouch for the
integrity of the results,
testing the trustworthiness
of a collaborator--
generally in subtle ways--
seems a good idea.
These days, I continue
to direct a laboratory,
as was just mentioned.
But I have limited time,
as you might imagine,
to spend with my trainees.
Therefore, I just have to
have a deep trust in them.
For instance, we just
published a paper
describing a new method of
making transgenic mice, which
is an unusual area
of investigation
for me to be involved in.
On the other hand, I had no
reason to doubt the findings.
It's, after all, hard to
fabricate a green mouse
or rat, which is what we made.
But I was glad that there were
a few people working closely
together on this project.
And actually, it is
really rare to come
across fraud in science.
Many postdocs and graduate
students with whom I've worked
have been searingly honest.
Checking, on the other
hand, is not a poor idea.
In world affairs, trust
is not in vogue today.
Its antithesis is war, and
we are living with war.
Rather than the open
and trusting society
we had not long ago we now
have airport guards screening
our shoes, border
guards screening us
at every portal of
entry to the country,
and an Olympics of FBI agents.
We are grateful
for the protection,
because we have been shown
that the world harbors enemies
who will use trust as a shield
to gain entry to our country,
to our facilities, and to
our transportation systems.
The wonderful thing
about the academic world
is that trust
remains a foundation
of all of our activities.
It goes beyond the
trust of colleagues
that is the foundation of
any intellectual community.
An important part of
the academic process
involves the trust that students
place in their teachers.
I'm sure we all remember the
terrible case of Joseph Ellis--
the Mount Holyoke historian who
invented his tour in Vietnam,
presumably to present himself
in a more exciting light
to his students.
When it became known that he
had never had the experiences
he recounted the whole academic
community was horrified.
He had not lied in his
teaching or his scholarship,
but even in just
lying about himself
he had broken the
trust that students
have for their teachers.
Honesty in the relationship
of students and teachers
is rarely questioned,
with trust freely given
and the rarity of cases
like that of Ellis
justifies that trust.
Another component of
the trust of academia
is the trust that parents
give that their offspring will
be treated with care and
respect when they send them
into the academic world.
Caltech and MIT get a very
similar sort of student,
and they're often headstrong
and difficult to manage.
But they are our responsibility,
and living up to the trust
placed in us is a
challenge we cannot shirk.
Trust plays a very
special role at Caltech,
because both undergraduate
and graduate student,
life is built around
an honor system.
The honor code of Caltech
states that, quote,
"No member shall take unfair
advantage of any member
community."
It's an awkward
phrase, but it works.
As our catalog says, it is more
than merely a code applying
to conduct and examinations.
It extends to all
phases of campus life.
It is the code for behavior
governing scholastic
and extracurricular activities,
relations among students,
and relations between
students and faculty.
It's adjudicated by a board of
control made up by students.
Is it perfect?
No.
But we in the Caltech
community live the honor code,
by giving all our examinations
as take home exams to be
governed by whatever the
particular set of rules that
were laid down by the examiner--
open book versus closed book,
time for completion of
the exam, et cetera.
Now, I suppose there
is a little cheating,
but basically it works.
And alumni say
that the honor code
is the most important lesson
of a Caltech education,
because it sets a standard
for their behavior
for the rest of their lives.
They have seen a
community based on trust
and on personal integrity, and
they know the value of trust
in creating a
community of interests.
Trust does break down
in the academic world
when there's misrepresentation,
plagiarism, or fraud.
And many of us can remember
that in the early 1990s,
this was a big issue, because
politicians were arguing
that fraud was
rampant in science,
and the press
picked up the issue.
That climate was at the
heart of the personal events
I lived through.
The suspicion of the
rectitude of scientists
has quieted down,
at least partly
because the community
put in place procedures
for dealing with
allegations of fraud.
My belief is that it was never
a big problem, that probably
the rate of incidents
has neither increased
nor decreased, but that the
visibility of the problem
has dropped away.
It is interesting that
today, not science,
but history is the field
where both plagiarism
and personal misrepresentation
have been major issues.
Personal integrity is crucial
in the field of history,
because the historian
is always making choices
about what facts to
emphasize, and is often
interpreting the motivations
of historic figures.
It's important to
remember that science too
has a subjective component.
That scientists select
data to present.
Science may be more
objective than history,
but all intellectual endeavor
depends on personal integrity.
Trust plays different roles
in different types of science.
A single investigator
working on a problem
can do personal
science requiring trust
in no other individual.
However, so much science
today is group science,
where many people contribute
to a single result
and group science
depends on trust.
This dependence
becomes magnified
as the number of interacting
people increases.
In projects that qualify as big
science, hundreds of scientists
may collaborate.
Actually, the word "science"
subsumes many different kinds
of investigations.
A simple categorization
might distinguish three types
of scientific investigation--
observational research,
hypothesis-driven research,
and technology development.
Let's look at them individually.
Observational science is
the modern incarnation
of the chief mode of studying
the world in early times.
Primitive people looked around,
saw the world given them,
and began to catalog it.
They named the
plants and animals.
They named the constellations.
They made hypotheses about
how the world came about,
which then became enshrined
in myth or religion.
But rather than
testing such ideas,
they accepted them and allowed
them to shape their worldview.
Today, instead of these
kinds of observations,
we observe molecular structures,
we observe gene structures,
we observe protein-protein
interactions.
We still do a lot of science
with the goal of describing
the world, but at finer and
finer scales of resolution.
Our accelerators and
our observatories
are often designed to
answer particular questions,
but the rationale for
their construction
is also to extend the
catalog of observations
to new energies of interaction,
for instance, or to new depths
of the universe.
Observational science today,
is done on a very large scale.
For biologists, we have
long looked into microscopes
and gasped at the
intimacy of nature.
The scale of today's
observational science
represents a qualitatively
new mode of investigation.
The most massive
enterprise of course,
is the Genome Project,
which is giving us
catalogs of information
about the genetic inheritance
of many organisms of this earth.
It involves the work of hundreds
of scientists, all of whom
must trust each other.
At Caltech, we are involved
in one of the great projects
of 21st century observation.
We're part of a consortium
making a virtual observatory
that will link the
observations of the sky, made
at all different wavelengths,
by different instruments, in one
terrifyingly huge, but
widely distributed database.
When it is complete, you will be
able to pick a spot in the sky
and get all of the information
available about that spot,
in an orchestrated search of
many individual databases held
in institutions
around the world.
It will include data at visible,
infrared, ultraviolet, radio,
and X-ray frequencies.
From recent work at
Caltech and elsewhere,
we may even include the
microwave background variation,
giving evidence of
what that region of sky
looked like in the years
just following the Big Bang.
I should add that Caltech
and MIT are jointly
involved in creating
one of the most
imaginative new observatories--
LIGO the Laser interferometry
Gravitational-wave Observatory.
This will look for a new form of
radiation-- gravity waves, that
have yet to be seen, but
have been firmly predicted
by Einstein as a
consequence of relativity.
Firmly means everybody
believes they will be seen.
Information from
LIGO will ultimately
become part of the virtual
observatory, but for the moment
we're just hoping to see
a signal of some sort
when it starts collecting
data next year.
There are many theories
predicting results,
but since no one's ever seen
the evidence of a gravity wave,
this is the ultimate form of
observational science, where
just making an
observation of any sort
will be considered
a huge victory.
The trouble with big science
is also its great strength--
it involves many
people working together
towards a particular end in
a collaborative enterprise
in which the contribution of the
individual is often obscured.
Furthermore, it often removes
from consideration one
of the chief motivations from
becoming involved in science--
the ability for an individual to
choose the questions he or she
wishes to work on.
Actually, when
students come to me
and ask what the difference
is between university-based
science and corporate
science I think
that's the main
difference to point to.
The ability in academia
when you're your own boss,
to do anything you wish, with
the only limitation being
finding the money to do it.
In companies, you're
usually constrained
to work on just
those problems that
contribute to corporate goals.
By contrast, early on in the
development of biotechnology,
companies scientists
had a lot of freedom.
But that freedom has
been severely restricted
because the industry
is maturing.
So big academic science
and corporate science
have homologies.
And one thing is
for certain, if you
want to develop your own
individuality in science,
you're better off working in
a small science framework.
Big science projects
are not good venues
for training the next
generation of scientists.
I suggested before there
are three modes of science.
The second--
hypothesis-driven science--
is often done in
a small-scale mode
by an investigator working
closely with a small group.
But high-energy physics, the
quintessential big science,
is generally hypothesis-driven.
In biology, the
hypotheses may come
from prior
observational science,
from an earlier
hypothesis-driven experiment,
or even occasionally
from theory.
In high-energy physics,
theory is often the driver.
Interestingly, astronomers
use enormous observatories
that are run by
dedicated staffs,
and that are very
expensive to maintain.
But whether they're developing
catalogs of celestial elements,
or are testing
particular ideas, they
work in a classic
small science mode,
with a single investigator
making observations.
Today, that investigator
is no longer
in a freezing cold
chamber open to the sky,
but in a cozy computer room,
often at a significant remove
from the chilled mirror
collecting the light.
The third mode of science
I differentiated before is
one that is rarely emphasized.
Technology development is often
considered to be engineering
and separated from science.
But when I came to Caltech,
one of the discoveries
I made about my job was that I
was responsible for operating
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
There, 5,000 people labor
to produce spacecraft
that either orbit
the Earth or that
go out into the solar system.
These spacecraft are
designed to do science.
The Hubble telescope is the
most notable of such spacecraft,
but there are lots of others
working at other wavelengths
and looking at other phenomena.
There are spacecraft
observing in Mars.
There are one circling
the earth looking
for meteorological events--
for instance, El Niño.
And there's even one
up there collecting
the particles of the solar
wind to return them to Earth,
so we can understand
what the sun is made of.
These spacecraft are
all doing science
so their design and
manufacture is a central part
of the scientific enterprise.
In the 1980s, Lee Hood,
then a professor at Caltech,
had the idea that technology
could advance biology,
much as technology was at
the center of Space science.
So he developed a group
to build hardware.
And their most
notable achievement
was the automated DNA sequencer.
Again, science was the goal--
the ability to sequence
large amounts of DNA,
but technology development was
the activity that they pursued.
And the Human Genome Project,
which depended entirely
on having automated
sequencing, was the proof
of how right Hood
was to concentrate
on this then very unfashionable
element of biological science.
For spacecraft,
technology development
involves very
high-end engineering,
because of the
unique constraints
of working in space.
The most obvious of
these constraints
is the cost of a
single satellite, which
ranges from a few
hundred million dollars
to a billion or more dollars.
With that kind of investment
in just one instrument,
it has to be built to
very high tolerances
to minimize the
possibility of failure.
Because of the enormous
propulsive forces
that are needed to leave
the Earth's atmosphere,
or even to get into
orbit around the Earth,
another constraint is
weight, with a huge premium
put on miniaturization.
Finally, power availability
on the spacecraft
is a key constraint, making
low-power instruments
a necessity.
Thus, literally thousands
of people's work
may be embodied in
a single satellite.
Do they all trust each other?
Actually, while
they certainly are
interdependent in
their activities,
they have developed
engineering systems
that check on the functioning
of each component.
They put each satellite
through a battery of tests,
often subjecting it
to conditions thought
to be much harsher than those
that they would encounter
when it flies in Space.
This is not because
of a lack of trust,
but because at that
level of complexity trust
is simply not sufficient.
You have to be sure.
One reason why spacecraft
are so phenomenally expensive
is because of the need
to monitor each step
and to test continually.
This was proven
in the mid 1990s.
You may remember that the then
NASA Administrator, Dan Goldin,
introduced the mantra of
faster, better, cheaper.
He wanted more satellites and
at a lower cost per mission.
Well, the consequence
was the two probes
sent to Mars failed, each
because of a very minor error.
In one, a conversion from
English to metric units
was missed.
In the other, a software
loop was missed.
The consequences for the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
were catastrophic.
Each was a tiny error--
99%+ of the technology
worked perfectly.
The lesson we learned
was that you could not
skimp on testing,
because in both cases
the kind of extensive testing
that had previously been done
was skipped in order to
satisfy a straightened budget.
An expensive lesson, but
one that has been learned.
So in some kinds of highly
interdisciplinary science,
trust is simply not enough--
not because of conscious
error, but because
of the catastrophic effects
of even inadvertent error.
But most
interdisciplinary science
is not so demanding
of perfection.
It involves a few people
bringing complementary skills
to a project.
But because each has
a separate skill,
they cannot easily
check on each other,
and one generally has to accept
the work of another as being
reliable.
Thus, the push to
interdisciplinary science--
which is evident today
throughout the academic world,
particularly when
studying questions
that are posed in biology--
that kind of
interdisciplinary work
requires a high degree of trust.
Let me spend a moment
on the importance
of interdisciplinary
work in biology.
What are particularly generative
of interdisciplinary approaches
are the massive observational
experiments that are underway.
The first of these
was the sequencing
of genomes, which required
the skills of mathematicians,
computer scientists,
engineers, geneticists,
and scientific entrepreneurs
to generate and handle
the huge volume of data.
But now having the
genome as a resource,
these same
complementary strengths
are being applied to
screening operations that
are designed to ferret
out regularities
that will be suggestive
of underlying biology.
And there's much more to
interdisciplinary activities
in biology.
For instance, there's extensive
work on new imaging systems
that bring physicists
and chemists together
with biologists.
There are efforts
to use the brain
to control prostheses that
meld the skills of roboticists
with neurophysiologists.
There are efforts
at miniaturization
of screening methods that
bring applied physicists
and engineers together
with biochemists.
One of the key
reasons that trust
is more critical
than ever in science
is that we have powerful
new tools that can
be used for data manipulation.
Photoshop is a paradigm here--
a program that can create
an artificial reality.
It is interesting
how easily we accept
the manipulation
of reality today
when, for instance,
we go to the movies.
In a sense it is the
ultimate realization
that photography is an art,
not a chronicle of reality.
When Man Ray went
into the darkroom
and created his
rayographs in the 1920s,
the art world was
shocked that photography
could be a medium in which one
painted abstractions directly
on film.
Today, we accept with equanimity
computer-generated images
as part of the artistic
process, whether in still images
or in movies.
Basically, we suspend trust
when we enter the realm of art,
and consciously put ourselves
in the hands of the artist.
This contrasts completely with
the scientific world, where
we trust implicitly that
reality has been preserved
and not created.
The problem is that the
tools are so powerful and so
pervasive that much data is
selected, digitally analyzed,
and possibly enhanced or
modified for effectiveness
of presentation.
This underscores the need
for trust, and, of course,
puts an onus on the
investigator to be
transparent about the
relation of the presented data
to the original.
In the larger world, trust
is a key to commerce.
Recently, the Enron
scandal has emphasized
how completely investment
was a matter of trust.
Enron was able to
hide from scrutiny
its financial
manipulations, but people
invested anyway taking at face
value whatever information was
presented by the company.
Trust is particularly
not in vogue
today in the investment world,
because so many people got
burned by Enron and
by other companies
that obscured their reality.
I've been involved for years
in biotechnology investment,
and I know firsthand
how difficult
it is to get reliable
information about any company.
One tries to minimize
the need for trust,
but without becoming
an insider and, thus,
greatly limiting your
freedom as an investor,
you cannot get much information
about the inner workings
of a company.
Because trust is an inevitable
part of any investment
decision, the personal integrity
of the management of a company
becomes a key element
in evaluation.
For, instance one of the
darlings of biotechnology
recently, has been
a company called
ImClone, a company that has
developed a very promising
anti-cancer drug.
Of course, validation of
the effectiveness of a drug
like this must be
done by the FDA--
the Food and Drug
Administration--
if the drug is to
get on the market.
And therefore, it's critically
important to an investor
to have an honest picture
of the interactions
between the company and the FDA.
However, the investment
world knew about ImClone,
that they had key personnel
in their management
with less than a
pristine background.
The difficulty is that
if one simply said,
we won't invest in a
company unless management
can be trusted
implicitly, we would
have missed one of the best
run-ups in the biotechnology
market in history.
So the investment people I
work with took the chance.
The stock did appreciate.
But then it emerged that the
management had apparently
not been honest about their
communication with the FDA,
and we, and lots of
others, got burned.
Life provides opportunities
for big changes.
Life sometimes precipitates
us into situations
for which our backgrounds
haven't even prepared us.
The biggest for me was going
from managing a laboratory
at MIT, to managing first
the Whitehead Institute,
and then to universities--
Rockefeller University
and now Caltech.
The movement from the
laboratory to the director's
or president's
office is a huge one,
because you go from directing a
unit where you have a long term
familiarity with
the working parts,
to one where there
are many elements that
are at best vaguely
comprehensible--
like the HVAC system,
or the payroll system,
or athletics, or
the mathematicians.
[LAUGHTER]
The latter are particularly
incomprehensible.
So I'm now in a position of
running an almost $2 billion
operation when you include JPL.
And what you
discover quickly when
you take on such
an enterprise, is
that you are deeply dependent
on each other to make it go.
Each vice president, each head
of a department or a division,
or even each head
of a laboratory,
has to be someone in whom
you can place your trust.
Not just that they
will be ethical,
but that they will be diligent
and effective in their jobs.
Another part of my life is
that about two years ago I
became a director of Amgen, the
world's largest biotechnology
company.
Shortly after I joined the
board, we got a new CEO.
And so I've had
a chance to watch
how he has chosen to manage
this $4 billion enterprise.
One piece of it was
remarkably simple--
he puts an extraordinary
amount of his energy
into the people of
Amgen. He evaluates them,
he promotes them, he interacts
with them, he organizes them,
and occasionally he even
has to terminate them.
But he's constantly
gauging whether or not
they continue to
deserve his trust.
He was trained at
General Electric, where,
if I understand correctly, this
style of management was honed.
He's taught me a lot about how
to manage a large institution--
it's the people, stupid.
In thinking about the role
of trust in our lives,
I must point to
our personal lives.
Even in our most
intimate relationships
with our children and our
partners trust is crucial,
and a breakdown of trust
paves the pathway to disaster.
The development of the
mortal sense of children
is an illuminating topic,
because a parent is always
wondering when children have
reached the age or the stage
when they can be trusted.
My 27-year-old
daughter tells me now
how she would sneak
out at night when
she was an early teenager
growing up in Cambridge.
I didn't trust her
to be out, but she
believed she deserved the
trust and took matters
into her own hands.
In retrospect, I
guess she was right.
At least she lived through the
experiences to become an adult.
Let me digress for a moment and
consider a more general issue--
trust is an interpersonal
interaction,
one of a myriad of interactions
that make up a society.
Some of these are rational
many are unexamined.
However, it is
evident that we're
entering a period of
scientific investigation
of interpersonal
interactions, that this
is going to have
profound implications,
particularly for
the Social Sciences.
Now, like most hard scientists--
some people don't think biology
is a hard science, but I do--
I grew up with the belief
that the social sciences
had appropriated the
title of science,
but were unable to provide
the output of understanding
that, at least, I
expected of a science.
In spite of the often rigorous
use of scientific methodology,
especially in
psychology, the insights
were at best good stories.
Even economics, for all
of its use of mathematics,
was unable to explain how human
beings make economic choices.
My mother, actually, was one
of the last of the Gestalt
psychologists.
They were a remarkable
group of thinkers
who tried very hard to develop a
mechanistic base of perception.
But they had to fail at this,
because they simply did not
know enough about the
brain to understand
how the brain perceives
the outside world.
The big change
today is that we're
learning about where in the
brain decisions are made,
and we can expect,
over the next decade,
to learn how decisions are made.
In spite of its
limited resolution,
with magnetic
resonance imaging we're
able to watch the
brains of people--
and also the brains of monkeys--
as they make decisions.
This is the beginning
of a social science
that can explain behavior.
At Caltech, our
social scientists
are working now closely
with systems neuroscientists
to begin to generate a science
of social interactions.
Economists, political
scientists, and psychologists
are designing
experimental systems
where humans make
choices, and are
beginning to see how the brain
handles this kind of problem.
Even our professor
of finance is now
totally consumed by the
idea that he can test
theories of financial behavior.
It all evolved from
a school of research
called experimental economics,
in which economists posed
problems to groups of people--
often in auction or
market emulations--
and then they see how people
behave and how they interact.
It's a classic mode of testing
a theory experimentally,
and it often shows that the
theory needs adjustment.
Moving these experiments
into the MRI machine
is a way of moving into
the black box where
the decisions actually occur.
What it is sure to
show is how emotion
interacts with rationality.
This type of thinking
is becoming pervasive
in the arts and humanities as
well as in the social sciences.
There are now people
trying to understand
how artistic appreciation
is registered in the brain.
Actually, they're
making more progress
than the social scientists,
because their issue is easier,
since it involves only
subjective experience and not
interpersonal interaction.
Meanwhile, at Caltech,
our philosophers
are becoming interested
in how the brain works,
while our neuroscientists
are becoming
interested in consciousness--
a confluence of investigation
that I think has
revolutionary possibilities.
I thought I would tell
you a little bit about one
of the most interesting
people working
at this intersection
of experiment
and social science at Caltech--
Jean Ensminger, a
cultural anthropologist
we hired recently.
She came only last
year after years
that we had spent searching
for an anthropologist whom
it made sense to
have at Caltech,
where we have this very
experimentally-oriented
social science group.
And actually, if any of you
read The Wall Street Journal,
you might have read
about her work a month
or so ago, when they featured.
What she and a small band
of others have been doing
is experiments to
understand the choice
behavior of people in
different types of societies.
Jean had worked in a
village in rural Kenya.
So she started there.
And the experiment she did had
to be very simple, because this
is a pre-literate population.
So it was about as
simple as you can get.
Give a person some money,
about a day's wage--
and they actually
use real money--
and ask them to share
it with another person.
Both of them know the
amount of money involved.
And if the second person
does not accept the gift,
then neither gets anything.
But if the gift is accepted
both keep their money.
So say player one gets
$10, and offers $1.
Player 2 may feel that
player 1 is being stingy,
and out of a sense of
fairness refuse the offer,
effectively punishing Player
1 by giving up the 1 dollar.
But if Player 1 offers $5, then
Player 2 is likely to accept,
and both will be $5 richer.
Now, do this experiment in a
subsistence community in Kenya,
in a small town in Missouri,
in a hunter-gatherer community
in Tanzania, in fact, in
some 15 different settings.
What you come up with tells a
lot about how societies work
and how individuals
approach each other.
In the least
developed communities
the Players 1 offer the least
percentage of their money.
In an American setting, they
offer close to a 50/50 split.
A conclusion is, that
being in a market society
leads to fairness,
if not altruism.
What would Karl Marx
think of that outcome?
Sam Bowles, who's involved
in such work, says,
quote, "Many people
thought markets would
make people selfish and amoral.
That view is at
least too simple,
if not just plain wrong.
Jean Ensminger says, "The
most altruistic and trusting
societies are those that are
the most market-oriented.
And another commentator said
that assumptions about trust
are built into a market economy.
Contrast these conclusions
with the conclusions
that the Enron scandal suggests.
Enron used the trust
that we have in markets
to convince investigators
that they should
put their money in Enron stock.
To have doubted their veracity
took a deeply suspicious
analyst.
But trusting is the
necessary response
of people in a market
economy, because without trust
the market could not exist.
The alternative to trust
would be perfect knowledge,
and there's no way to get that.
In fact, as I noted
earlier, if you
do have a deep
knowledge of a company,
then you become an insider.
This experiment
that I described,
and other experiments like
it, are putting some meat
on the bones of
concepts like trust.
They defined such vague concepts
in an experimental setting,
making them operational terms
like the many others that
are used in science.
For instance,
other investigators
have been looking at what people
do when they act cooperatively.
This has generated
the unlikely concept
of altruistic punishment.
Members of a group will
punish those in the group
for not acting reasonably, even
if the punisher gains nothing
by the punishment.
I've been skeptical of
what has been a controlling
notion in biology--
that is the notion
of the selfish gene.
It's a notion which
derives from the belief
that a person will act
toward another person
in altruistic ways if that other
person is a blood relative.
And the idea is, that we
act to favor our own genes
because the genes are
driving us to that behavior.
I see these experimental
economics results raising
a very different
paradigm, and one that
strikes me as more meaningful.
They're perhaps
not contradictory,
but I wonder whether the
selfish gene will ultimately
succumb to notions of trust and
cooperation among relatives.
This talk has been an
unusual one for me to give.
It came about because
I found myself
so often facing the issue
of trust in my dealings
with the world.
I hope that I have made
all of you just a little
more aware of this central
element of human relations.
At the same time,
I hope I've raised
the question of whether such
a fundamental concept of trust
may not soon be a subject
of scientific study.
As a university
president, I find
myself thinking
about the directions
of scientific
investigation, and I
think I see that an
important direction is
the serious encroachment
of scientific thinking
into provinces
where it previously
could not be applied.
I find this exciting,
especially if it
leads to more effective
human interrelations.
And I thank you all very
much for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Thank you,
Professor Baltimore.
And he's agreed to take
questions from the audience.
And I think there were
some microphones around,
and we can have people come up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Professor Baltimore.
I would like to get your
opinion regarding altruism
amongst one's relatives.
I'm a recent postdoc, and I
feel that perhaps the greatest
erosional force that I
worry about contributing
to the demise of trust
within the sciences,
derives not from the
fear of incorrect or even
fictitious data,
but rather relates
to communicating valid
findings, and is derivative
of the incredible pressure put
upon researchers by competition
for recognition, publication
priority, and funding.
In short, it seems
that nothing is
to be trusted to
one's colleagues,
nothing is to be shared,
until it is published
or at the very least in press
in a journal with a very
rapid turnaround time.
Do you have any
comments about what
we, as a scientific community,
can do to stem this tide.
BALTIMORE: That's a
very difficult question.
I recognize that it is.
And it is difficult because
of the very strong competition
that exists among
scientific groups today,
something which is easy
to rue, but very hard
to do anything about.
When I grew up in science,
over the last 40 years,
it was the ethic of the
times to talk about anything
you were doing--
published or not.
And I remember being very
annoyed with a few scientists
who never seemed to
talk about anything
but published data or data
very soon to be published.
Because, why go to a
talk if you can read it?
You go to a talk to try to
get either a different kind
of synthesis or to get more
contemporary, and maybe less
certain, information.
And I agree, it's harder
to get that today.
It's harder to
find people who are
willing to talk about
what they're doing,
rather than what
they've already done.
To talk about things which
are a little less certain,
rather than the things that
they've already put their stamp
on and put into print.
And it is partly--
maybe even largely--
a matter of not
wanting the quote "competition"
to know what is going on.
It's a sad commentary
on science,
when it reaches that point.
Because we presumably grew up
with the notion that science is
a collaborative activity,
and that competition--
although necessary and
humanly understandable--
shouldn't be the driving force.
But I'm afraid, with the
number of scientists involved,
for instance, in the biological
sciences-- which I know best--
it's very hard to maintain
the kind of civility
that you'd like to maintain.
So I think we lose something
from the size and actually
effectiveness of our community
of scientists in incivility,
and I don't know
how to change it
except to behave
differently, and to try
to prove to people that you can
be effective and still be open.
And I believe that's correct.
But I can tell you
that today, when
I go to the people
in my lab and say,
I'd like to talk about the
work you're doing at a meeting,
and they say well, let's
wait until it's published,
or let's wait until
it's written up.
And I understand why
they're saying it,
but it certainly
doesn't make me happy.
So I haven't helped you,
but I've agreed with you.
And maybe to too great a length.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the
early 80s, there
was fairly substantial
faculty controversy
over the founding
of the Whitehead--
a connected, but
autonomous institution.
Could you comment
on the Whitehead
as a case study of
the role of trust
in building such an unusual,
and yet, over time, tremendously
successful organization?
BALTIMORE: Yes I can.
I think the reason that
the Whitehead Institute--
and I was talking with some
people about it earlier today--
worked so well, was
that my interest
was in building an
institution that would last.
And an institution
that lasts can't
be focused on an individual.
It has to be focused on a
process which guarantees
its continued excellence.
And I think it was
putting in place
that process, through
the affiliation agreement
that we had with MIT, as well
as through the way we worked it
out in practice-- because you
can never imagine everything
that's going to happen.
I think that's
what made it work.
And so I'm a great
believer that you
have to put in place processes
which are the underlying
strength of institutions.
And what Whitehead shows
is that those processes
can be evolved very rapidly.
They don't have to be inherited
from your forefathers.
You don't have to be
Harvard University
to have processes in
place which can guarantee
the strength of an institution.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know exactly when,
but at sometime in the
future it should be possible
for perhaps a single
graduate student or a postdoc
to create in a
university laboratory
some kind of pathogen
that if let loose
might cause very grave
harm, kill very many people,
or worse.
And I'm wondering right now we
can sort of trust that maybe
that's not happening.
And I'm wondering what
can we do in the future?
BALTIMORE: That's
a good question,
because I think you've put
it in the right context.
Today, we are not
yet to the point
where we have to worry
about it terribly.
What we're in fact
discovering is
that pathogenesis is a
very complicated concept,
and involves the interaction of
lots of different components.
And so it's not easy to modify
it and make things worse.
But we'll understand
it well enough,
and we'll figure
out how to do it.
And in fact, in some
very simplistic ways,
the Russians may
have actually been
trying to do that in the 80s.
But I think what's
going on now, which
is to try to register the
laboratories that are involved
in work with pathogens, and to
keep some kind of surveillance
of what's going on, may
be a necessary thing.
Doesn't make me happy.
But on the other hand, I think
we really do have to watch out.
Your suggestion was that a
single individual working
on their own in a laboratory
might be sufficient to do this,
and the implication
is that nobody around
would know what they're doing.
So the second thing is openness
about what people are doing.
The most dangerous
thing is secrecy.
Now, I really believe
that we're better off
in dealing with
pathogens and whatever
to have openness about what's
being done rather than secrecy.
Previously, we had secrecy.
Biological warfare was done
behind barriers of secrecy.
Nobody knew what was going on.
Turns out, not a
lot was going on,
but no one knew what it was.
Today, we have openness about
biological warfare research
in principle.
But our government today is
moving to increased secrecy.
You can see in the headlines
in the papers every day.
And that could put
us right back where
we were, but with much
more powerful tools--
tools of recombinant
DNA research--
that will allow, in
principle, the production
of more pathogenic organisms.
I will remind you that
the anthrax that we
saw being distributed
through the mails
probably came from a laboratory.
We don't really know
where it came from,
but probably came from
fairly expert manufacture.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: New York Times, front
page today, top right corner,
headline-- the Pentagon
wants to start an office,
is admitting to starting an
office to focus or fabricate
information to motivate
people, support--
inside and outside
the US-- for their war
on terrorism, as they call it.
Is this a loss of naivety on
the side of the public, because,
obviously, if I
was the Pentagon,
I would try to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Why are they stating that
obviously to everyone?
Do they want to
make it legitimate?
Do they want to create a
climate where things like that
are more tolerated?
At the same time, they
want more observation,
more technology to observe
what people are doing.
What is going on?
I mean--
BALTIMORE: Right.
I'm shocked!
The Pentagon is putting
out disinformation!
[LAUGHTER]
I agree with you completely
in the implication
of your question.
That is, who should be
surprised that they're doing it?
No one.
It's been done for years.
Every organization puts
out disinformation.
Enron, to the fore.
And why was there's an article?
I think because a couple
of hotshot reporters
suddenly had evidence that
it was happening, and wrote
an article about it.
I was not at all surprised to
discover that was going on.
But it doesn't make
me happy to know
that the Pentagon is trying
to manipulate the press--
particularly the foreign press.
But, no, I'm not surprised.
AUDIENCE: Trust sometimes,
well, more often than not,
being a delicate
issue of balance,
people or institutions
find themself in positions
where they have to try for
trust from different sides.
Such as a university
is striving for trust
from parents who are
sending their kids there,
as well as from the kids.
Now, sometimes it may,
sometimes it may not
be contradicting
things that you would
feel you should act like to
gain the trust of these sites.
So you have to obtain a balance
to gain trust from both sides.
Can you comment,
or give an example,
how Caltech is dealing with that
issue and keeping the balance?
I mean, in this hands of
reassuring the parents
that the kids are taken care of
and their welfare is assured,
and assuring the kids that
they have room to grow,
that, they have room
to unfold themself?
BALTIMORE: You've hit on one
of the stickiest problems
that we have at Caltech,
probably that all institutions
have, and that we're
just now trying
to figure out how to deal with.
I'll put a different
way-- how do
you allow students
to have autonomy
in the pursuit of
their education,
and at the same
time guarantee both
their safety and their
growth as individuals?
And it's a delicate balance.
We, in the United States,
for instance, generally
have students in
most universities
in some kind of a dormitory
housing situation,
particularly as freshmen.
And I know that MIT is going
to house all of its freshmen
in dormitories.
Abroad, people go to college
and they live in apartments.
And they don't live in
controlled circumstance.
They make all their
own decisions.
So there are various
sorts of models
of how you take the
responsibility that's
being handed to you
by people sending
their children to college.
And all I can say
is that I'm trying
to wrestle with that
balance today, myself,
and I don't know where it sits.
But I do know it's a changing
societal framework that we're
living with.
Changed enormously from the
time when I was in college,
and all of our activities
were second-guessed.
But I don't think we've found
the right mix, particularly
with the potentially
self-destructive things that
are available in our society
today-- drugs and alcohol being
the two major ones.
It's very difficult to know
where to strike that balance.
So another question
I haven't answered.
MODERATOR: One more question,
I think, and then we'll go.
AUDIENCE: You use the word
"trust" to cover everything
from someone possibly being
dishonest to not checking
calculations enough.
That's goes beyond what I would.
I would say belief,
might come into that.
Or you could use trust,
but the meaning of it
spreads out in
different directions.
But what really
made me wonder was
you said that decisions
would, in the next 10 years,
be greatly better understood
by study of the brain.
If you are trying to
appoint someone to a job,
say, where you have
all different kinds
of trust in them--
from moral, to believing they
have talent, to believing they
have certain
qualities of character
that will do the job well.
It's such a tremendously
complex thing.
How can you read
things from the state
of the brain that are
really going to get you
to the heart of that?
Particularly considering that
if I am looking into your brain,
and deciding that
you've made a decision
because you have certain
attitudes about things
outside yourself--
the state of the world, the
state of another person--
I have to judge whether
you're right as well.
So it seems like
there's a gap there
in what can be understood
by studying the brain.
BALTIMORE: I think we're
mixing up two things.
I was suggesting that
by studying the brain,
we could begin to understand
the concepts that are involved
in interpersonal
relations, and how
those are translated into
actual brain activity, which
is what we can measure today.
We'll measure more than
that in the future.
I wasn't suggesting that we
use that as a diagnostic tool
to figure out whether an
individual is trustworthy
or not.
I suppose it might come
to that, but I really
hadn't even thought of that.
And was certainly not
suggesting that that's
the direction we're going in.
I was talking much
more about how
you scientifically
investigate the elusive
concepts of social science.
MODERATOR: I think we should
thank Professor Baltimore once
more, and there's a
reception out in the lobby.
[APPLAUSE]